imágenes que muestran la dimensión de la
tragedia un enorme glaciar del himalaya
se desprendió de la ladera de una
montaña este domingo y se precipitó al
cauce de un río y golpeando con fuerza
las laderas del valle
nos estamos asegurando de que aquellos
que están varados debido a que los
puentes han sido arrastrados y debido a
la ausencia de otros puentes no se
enfrenten a ninguna escases de raciones
o alimentos ampliaremos nuestros
esfuerzos para ayudar a las personas que
están atrapadas lo antes posible a
través de nuestros equipos de rescate
las autoridades dijeron que el enorme
deslizamiento de hielo provocó torrentes
de agua que rompieron una presa en
construcción arrastrando puentes y
carreteras a su paso en el distrito de
chabolas del estado de uttar acan entre
las posibles víctimas se encontrarían
trabajadores del proyecto hidroeléctrico
así como habitantes de la aldea que
deambulan cerca del río en busca de leña
o pastoreando su ganado el primer
ministro indio narendra modi reaccionó
estoy monitoreando constantemente la
desafortunada situación en huracán india
apoya out arakan y la nación reza por la
seguridad de todos allí he estado
hablando continuamente con las máximas
autoridades y recibiendo actualizaciones
sobre el despliegue de la fuerza
nacional de respuesta a desastres el
trabajo de rescate y las operaciones de
socorro
el ministro del interior anunció el
envío de equipos de socorro y rescate
por vía aérea un tarakan en el himalaya
es propenso a inundaciones repentinas y
desprendimientos de tierra en junio de
las lluvias récord provocaron
inundaciones devastadoras que se
cobraron cerca de seis mil vidas